we've discovered an interview with miles
garrett the browns defensive end who has
been reinstated reinstated wednesday
interviewed by espn
on
thursday and as part of this new
interview miles garrett doubles down on
his claim that mason rudolph the
steelers quarterback used a racial slur
in the moments preceding miles garrett
removing the helmet of mason rudolph and
whacking him over the head with it and
oh look and let's be clear on this
garrett has made the accusation in the
past the first time he's made it
publicly in the past it was at his
appeal hearing and he supposedly wasn't
happy that it got out
this time he
reiterated it he repeated it he got into
details about what was said he said
initially he tried to walk away rudolph
kept coming that's when he kind of blew
a fuse
um look shireen
i got two things to say about this first
first
if you really don't want to use it as
justification for what you did why are
you talking about it at all why is it
part of the interview why is it part of
the ground rules with espn though i
don't want this coming up i don't want
you asking me about the racial slur that
i claim mason rudolph used i don't want
that to be part of this discussion i i
think they're trying to have it both
ways they want him to be able to say
well this really isn't justification but
they want people who hear it to say well
that's justification because i'd have
done the same thing if the guy used that
word to me so they're walking a very
fine line here when it comes to
on one hand saying i don't believe it's
justification for what i did i don't
want people to think i'm saying that to
at the same time
hoping in a roundabout way that people
hear that and say yes it justifies what
he did
yeah and it it's not going to justify no
matter what he says no matter what he
heard
nothing is going to justify his actions
and that's what tony dungy said uh you
know when you talk to to him it doesn't
matter what was said to him you have to
keep your cool you can't act like that
that's the first time i think that we've
seen
an act really go over the total edge
like that i know no damage and sue did
something stomped on andre gerard's head
and things like that but this to me was
just completely and totally over the top
something we had never seen before and
hopefully never see again and no matter
what was said no matter what was done
you cannot do that on a football field
or elsewhere and if it was elsewhere
he'd be in jail right now
and actually it was in dominic and sue
stomping on the arm of evan dietrich
smith and accidentally stepping on the
calf of aaron rodgers it was albert
haynesworth who stomped on the
helmetless head of andre garrod and got
suspended five games for that that had
been the most egregious thing we'd seen
but even this swinging that helmet i'm
still amazed that mason rudolph wasn't
injured and if he had been injured it
would have been far worse than six games
for miles garrett but it was one of the
most shocking on-field displays we've
ever seen and tony dungy i was surprised
when he shared his views with me because
look i i on one hand i'm saying well
mason rudolph should not be using
language like this but on the other hand
on a football field you got to be ready
to hear anything and that's what tony
dungy said here is coach dungy from the
november 24th edition of pft live
i'm sorry i don't have sympathy with
miles garrett if in fact that is what
happened if we're on the bottom of the
pile and mason rudolph is kneeing you in
the groin or he's trying to poke your
eye out or he's twisting your knee
going to affect your ability to do your
work in your career then yeah you can go
off but you can't go off because
somebody said something to you all kinds
of things get said out there on the
field i can't go off and jeopardize my
team's chances to go to the playoffs my
career my ability to make money because
somebody called me a name i don't care
what name he said that is not an excuse
to me
and coach dungey later added that this
is an issue that miles garrett should
have taken up with mason rudolph after
the game let's have a conversation about
this inappropriate language you're using
or
and this is my thought take it to the
officials we see players complain to the
officials all the time i'm being held
i'm being interfered with he's grabbing
at me he's pulling at me you see what he
did you see what he did he took he took
a swing at me they do that all the time
and several years ago the nfl made it
clear that any type of slurs would be
dealt with so you say to the official do
you hear what this guy said to me and
you deal with it that way you don't take
the law into your own hands you don't
rip the guy's helmet off and hit him
over the head with it and shireen this
leads to the other point that i wanted
to make and this is something you
mentioned yesterday and we can now
underscore it highlight it circle it put
it in red put it in yellow put it in
every color possible because
he's going to hear it more
he is good right or wrong and i don't
think god should be using this language
on the field but the reality is he's
going to be hearing everything in the
book he's going to be hearing stuff
about his mother about his sister if he
has one he's going to be hearing it
non-stop because by him
we already knew
that he was going to be baited
incessantly but this interview takes it
that next step farther
it's clear that you can say things that
will get under his skin
and that's what's going to happen i mean
guys are going to go at him relentlessly
trying to get that 15-yard penalty
trying to get him kicked out of the game
and look he had a lot of 15-yard
penalties last season and most of them
were for late hits on quarterbacks but
they're going to be trying to get him to
do things and do you not think the
officials are going to be watching his
every move absolutely they are anything
he does that's even barely over the line
he's going to get a penalty for so this
is this is going to be something he's
going to have to deal with from now on
in his career it's not it's a stain
that's not going away it's just going to
be there with for with him
for the rest of his career officials
going to be watching him claire's going
to be trying to bait him
whatever he's got to learn to keep us
cool and hopefully he's had some help in
learning how to do that because it's
obvious he can't do that on his own
well here's the other side of it shireen
if the officials are going to be
watching everything he says and does and
how he reacts to what players on the
opposing team say to him i think it's
incumbent on the officials to listen to
how over the top the other players are
in their handling of and treatment of
miles garrett if it really is this
free-for-all now where you've got
everybody on the opposing team
constantly
hurling insults and using slurs and
expletives at miles garrett at a certain
point you've got to protect garrett from
this onslaught especially since the nfl
several years ago did begin this process
remember there was a fine of colin
kaepernick at one point for using the
n-word during a game um and there have
been other players who have been accused
of using it there have been officials
who've been accused of using it but i
think that their the tools are there for
the officials to protect other players
from miles garrett physically but also
to protect miles garrett from excessive
verbal abuse aimed at getting him to
blow a fuse
well and and miles just needs to stop
talking at this point he said what he's
needed to say he needs to quit talking
about this and move on and and get
things together and and start getting
ready for next year and not worry about
what was done then let's worry about
what we can do now to not have this
happen again and again i i think i hope
that he went and got some help and and
had some therapy and learned how to use
that aggression that he has it's what
makes him a really good player he had 10
sacks in 10 games last year he has 30
and a half in his career he's a really
good player but he's got to learn to use
that aggression
for him and not against him which we've
seen way too many times in his career so
far
i mean it's obvious to me the decision
to sit down with espn yesterday was
a strategic move that i think had been
in the works for a long time he was
going to sit down with jay glazer a fox
right after the incident somebody pulled
the plug on that either garrett's camp
or the browns or a little bit of both
they didn't want to say anything that
could or would have been used against
him by the league so once he's free and
clear to get back in that's when he
tells his story and again i don't buy
the idea that now he may think it
doesn't justify what he does or he may
think that's what he needs to say but
telling this story and continuing to
harp on the notion that a slur was
uttered is the kind of thing that will
get some people to say well now i
understand why he did what he did
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports